hello
I want to make video because I think
some people are confused about what is
the sexy so some people think the sexy
is just the sex and the sexy is not just
the sex the sex is good
everybody like the sex you can't have
the sex all day you can't have the sex
with all the people
so the sexy you can have all the day the
sexy you can have people I see Oh
grandmother I don't want to have sex
with all grandmother but that's he oh
girl mother I said hello grandmother
I love you and she said Oh sexy young
man sexy men said oh he loved me and she
said I love you too I see you Oh
grandfather
I think hey old grandfather I love you
honey go ahead sexy young man he say
love me he said I love you too I see
butterfly
I said hey butterfly I love you and
butterfly just butterfly so butterfly
just just right
but it's the power of the sexy mr. love
the power of a sexy you can share with
all the world all the people are also
good for the sex yeah
if you find the person you want to have
set are the people you have the sex too
but it's bigger than just the sex
[Music]
okay so i living in forest i happy and I
hope you somewhere in that you happy -
okay bye
[Music]
you